la guerre actuelle en Ukraine n'a pas
commencé le 24 février 2022 mais en 1999
avec l'arrivée au pouvoir de Vladimir
Poutine c'est ce que soutient le député
européen Raphaël Glucksmann dans son
nouvel essai la grande confrontation il
lui explique comment Vladimir Poutine a
profité de l'aveuglement de l'Occident
et de la corruption de l'élite politique
pour déstabiliser nos démocraties je les
joins un peu plus tôt à Paris et mon
invité est aussi c'est important
président de la commission spéciale du
Parlement européen sur l'ingérence
étrangère il vient de publier un rapport
le 1er juin on l'écoute
Raphaël docksmann bienvenue à 24 60
merci d'invitation mais elle est toute
naturelle dans la foulée de nos
couvertures on doit s'intéresser aux
sortes de l'Ukraine parce que tout au
long de cet ouvrage vous nous dites que
c'est notre guerre à nous et vous
stérilinski lors de son premier discours
après l'invasion au Britannique
s'inspirant de Shakespeare être ne pas
être donc c'est aussi notre guerre à
nous n'est-ce pas vous en êtes vraiment
convaincu
cette guerre est la guerre de l'Europe
et de l'Occident général parce que nous
sommes la cible de Vladimir Poutine
n'est pas depuis seulement le 24 février
2022 depuis bien plus longtemps nous
sommes la cible des attaques et des
ingérences de Vladimir Poutine et
derrière l'Ukraine c'est nous qui sommes
visés c'est l'ensemble des démocraties
libérales et j'aimerais juste qu'on
fasse une expérience qu'on ferme les
yeux et qu'on se dise dans quelle
situation nous serions aujourd'hui en
Europe et dans le monde libre si zenki
n'avaient pas répondu à byden le jour de
l'invasion je n'ai pas besoin de
munitions je n'ai pas besoin de taxi
j'ai besoin de munitions si l'état
ukrainien ne s'était pas
de cette manière comporter et elle
n'avait pas de cette manière résister
s'il s'est détendrait si les plans du
Kremlin avaient abouti dans quelle
situation nous serions aujourd'hui nous
serions face à un régime tyrannique qui
aurait gagné la guerre et qui serait
aujourd'hui en train de menacer des pays
membres de l'OTAN et donc si les
Ukrainiens ont résisté ils ont résisté
pour eux-mêmes mais aussi pour
l'ensemble de l'Europe et nous avons une
dette vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine qui est
aujourd'hui notre première ligne de
défense
ukrainien comme d'une vertu collective
vous et oui zelinsky était là donc
c'était pas il y avait plus de prorus en
Ukraine mais plus tard dans votre essai
vous dites et si Trump avait été
président des États-Unis que serait-il
arrivé
c'est presque une tragédie c'est Trump
avait été au pouvoir à ce moment là
n'est-ce pas
et c'est une immense leçon pour l'Europe
on peut pas dépendre exclusivement du
locataire de la Maison Blanche vous
savez tous les quatre ans les Européens
regardent les élections dans le méchant
du Michigan ou dans le vice consigne en
une nuit blanche en se demandant si le
vote de ses électeurs qui ne connaissent
pas et bien va garantir ou pas la
sécurité de Vilnius de Varsovie ou de
Prague et ça ne peut pas durer comme ça
il faut désormais qu'on soit capable
d'assumer notre propre défense en Europe
qu'on soit capable de ne pas dépendre
exclusivement de l'identité du locataire
américain parce que nous avons une
chance folle que Biden soit président au
moment de la vision de l'Ukraine et la
question qui doit tous nous tarauder
c'est est-ce que Biden et bien c'est la
vérité continue des États-Unis ou est-ce
que et Trump dans ce cas là n'était
qu'une parenthèse ou est-ce qu'il y a
des tendances à long terme qui
engendreront une forme de retrait
américain et ça c'est quelque chose qui
doit nous obséder nous Européens
qu'aurions nous fait si Donald Trump
avait été président aux Etats-Unis et
bien la vérité elle est triste à dire
c'est que l'Europe n'aurait pas été
capable d'aider suffisamment l'Ukraine
pour qu'elle résiste l'Europe ne
produisait plus d'armement suffisant
l'Europe n'avait plus d'armée
suffisamment forte et l'Europe ça avait
en fait délégué la fonction de de
protection militaire et de sécurité
entièrement aux États-Unis d'Amérique et
vivaient dans La Poste histoire et c'est
cette page là qui se tourne et désormais
il faut en Europe on soit capable
d'assurer notre sécurité et qu'on soit
capable aussi de comprendre que
l'histoire n'est pas finie que toutes
les femmes des années 90 et bien sont
révolus désormais nous devons admettre
que nous avons des adversaires des
adversaires extrêmement puissants qui
cherchent à ébranler nos démocraties et
à rejeter les systèmes libéraux dans
lesquels nous vivons la démocratie
mortelle écrivez-vous d'ailleurs sur
Trump un mot parce que la campagne
présidentielle est déjà enclenchée ici
il se voit déjà à nouveau président il
dit déjà qu'il règlerait la guerre en
Ukraine en 24 heures et vous parler du
vertige engendré par toutes ces
questions et qui fait et ce risque que
fait que fait peser la corruption sur
notre sécurité collective parce qu'au
fond revenons au tout début de votre
essai et vous c'est la grande
journaliste russe assassinée à la
politesse en 2005 est il y aura la
guerre personne ne l'a vu personne ne
l'a entendu elle est assassinée mais
ensuite vous dit que cette guerre que
l'on vit aujourd'hui a commencé en 1999
à la chute de l'Union soviétique et
ensuite les grandes années
2008-2014 la Crimée 2015 la série 2017
le hacking en France on peut dire
maintenant également la guerre en
Ukraine c'est toute une système Poutine
là qui s'est déployé pendant cette
vingtaine d'années
oui ce que j'essaye d'étudier dans mon
livre c'est la continuité du régime de
Poutine parce que tous les ministres
tous les présidents tous les dirigeants
tous les diplomates qui se sont trompés
sur Poutine pendant 20 ans nous explique
aujourd'hui qu'il a changé que le
partenaire avec lesquels il signait des
contrats gaziers a été remplacé par une
espèce de fou dingue mais la vérité
c'est pas ça la vérité c'est que cette
guerre était en gestation depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir de Vladimir Poutine
il a commencé son règne par la guerre
par la guerre en Tchétchénie plus de
100000 morts sur un million d'habitants
et ensuite il a fait vivre constamment
son peuple le peuple russe dans un état
de guerre il a fait vivre dans l'état de
guerre avec la Géorgie avec l'Ukraine
avec la scierie avec la révolution
syrienne et derrière tous ces
adversaires à chaque fois ce que vendait
le régime russe à son peuple c'est
l'ennemi occidental c'est l'Occident
collectif et tout cela nous avons refusé
de le voir nous nous avons refusé de
voir ce qui se tramait à Moscou et c'est
ce que nous annonçait les lanceurs
d'alerte Russie à napolitovsker qui n'a
été ni écouté ni entendu parler
dirigeants occidentaux et donc ce livre
c'est une enquête sur ce cocktail
complètement d'étonnant qui a paralysé
l'Occident pendant 20 ans vis-à-vis de
la Russie de Poutine qui est un cocktail
à la fois de corruption et j'étudie les
réseaux russes dans les hautes sphères
de la politique
occidentale et de naïveté il y avait
ceux qui touchaient de l'argent comme
par exemple le chancelier allemand
guerre Schröder qui a pris les décisions
qui ont créé la dépendance énergétique à
l'égard de la Russie la dépendance
énergétique de l'Allemagne et donc du
reste de l'Europe donc il y avait ceux
qui touchaient de l'argent ce qui était
au service du régime russe et il y avait
tous les autres ce qui n'était pas
corrompu mais qui eux ont fait preuve
d'une indolence d'une naïveté d'une
absence totale de lucidité et
aujourd'hui
et bien il est important de faire la
lumière sur cela pour ne pas reproduire
les mêmes erreurs non seulement avec la
Russie Poutine mais aussi par exemple
avec la Chine de Gigi bling
parce que blinken était là aujourd'hui
mais dans votre sexe que vous démontrez
c'est que la guerre et la fin elle-même
et vous citez le vice-président de la
Douma la guerre est une idéologie
nationale c'est dans l'ADN est-ce qu'on
peut dire des Russes ou de Poutine
de Poutine et du régime russe dans son
ensemble et il a inculqué ça aujourd'hui
à la société russe vous savez beaucoup
de gens se demandent en Occident
pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'y a pas assez
grande révoltes à travers la Russie mais
parce que nous nous pensons que le 24
février 2022 est une rupture totale
entre l'avant et l'après la vérité c'est
que pour les citoyens russes ils étaient
en guerre depuis longtemps ça fait
longtemps qu'on leur explique qu'ils
sont en guerre contre l'Occident et puis
entre Tolstoï le vice-président de la
Douma a dit la guerre est notre
idéologie nationale mais ça vient à la
suite des discours de Vladimir Poutine
qu'on a refusé d'écouter et d'entendre
ça vient la suite des textes publiés par
les gens les plus proches de Poutine
dont par exemple monsieur sorchos qui
est le chef d'orchestre si vous voulez
du régime de Poutine depuis 1999 et qui
nous explique que l'exportation du chaos
en Occident et la seule garantie de
survie de ce régime et à la tête de la
Commission spéciale sur les ingérences
étrangères du Parlement européen moi
j'ai étudié toutes les campagnes de
déstabilisation toutes les campagnes de
manipulation de l'information
rendez-vous il peut tout à fait signer
des contrats gaziers avec vous et dans
le même temps cherchez à déstabiliser
votre démocratie
désespérantes de cécité parce que quand
vous avez parlé de garage Schreder vous
vous parlez un de choix dérisation si on
veut de la transformation du système
donc même pas moi qui parle de
sonorisation c'est les Russes ils ont
inventé ce terme ils ont inventé ce qui
est génial après le cas de Shredder ils
ont inventé le concept de schroderie
zattia de la classe politique européenne
ça veut dire la transformation de la
classe politique européenne dans un
supermarché dans lequel on peut venir
faire ses courses en toute quiétude et
là effectivement la choisirisation est
intéressante de voir ça quand ensuite on
a financé la guerre en Ukraine pendant
des mois à cause de ce fameux noms
stream et les entends mais vous parlez
d'une guerre de chaos elle passe aussi
beaucoup par prigogène l'Internal
l'Internet research agency les les
hacking vous l'avez vécu en France on
l'a vécu aux États-Unis en 2016 dont est
en plein débat politique sur l'ingérence
étrangère alors je vous demande pas que
nécessairement de commenter la situation
ici parce que vous dites que la
bureaucratie est un grand ennemi de la
démocratie ici donc nous dirigeants
politiques ont pas lu les mémos qu'ils
avertaient sur l'ingérence je poste
assez rendu chez vous à Bruxelles cette
histoire-là mais en tout cas c'est grave
les risques que l'on court en ce moment
avec cette ingérence n'est-ce pas
mais chez nous non plus les dirigeants
ne lisaient ni les mémos de leur
bureaucratie ni les mémos des services
de sécurité étaient un immense problème
et je pense que bien sûr il faut faire
la lumière et ce qui me m'interpelle moi
c'est à quel point nous avons un niveau
de tolérance vis-à-vis de ces ingérences
parce que c'est pas juste des mots en
l'air par exemple quand les hackers
russes attaquent l'hôpital de
Corbeil-Essonnes pas loin de Paris et
bien pendant des mois les patients les
docteurs n'ont plus accès au dossier
médicaux des patients et donc les
patients français ne peuvent plus être
soignés normalement dans cet hôpital
français et on a comme ça des séries de
cas à travers toute l'Europe et donc
comment peut-on justifier le fait que
des dirigeants si vous voulez
qu'ils sacrifie les tchétchène ou les
Géorgiens c'est immoral mais ils peuvent
toujours le faire au nom du réalisme
société une erreur fondamentale mais
c'était au nom du réalisme de la Real
politique mais comment vous pouvez
justifier votre inaction quand c'est
votre propre pays qui est traité comme
une serpillière quand les agents de
Vladimir Poutine vont assassiner
[Musique]
à la Douma parce qu'on ne dit pas élu on
dit nommer à la Douma par Poutine et et
quand il a gagné ses fake élection et
bien il accueille la presse occidentale
avec un t-shirt marqué polonium en gros
et comment on peut tolérer ça comment le
Royaume-Uni a-t-il plutôt les récemment
l’allemagne a-t-elle plutôt toléré et
continuer à signer des contrats gaziers
avec un régime qui a tué des gens
les opposants tchétchen au coeur même de
Berlin dans des parcs comment est-ce que
en fait on a pu autoriser un tel régime
à nous traiter de la sorte là c'est même
plus une question de real politique
c'est juste une question de soumission
et de d'incapacité à engager un rapport
de un rapport de force avec un régime
qui veut votre père alors votre appel au
réalisme quand même est percutant vous
parlez de Macron effectivement qui
disait il faut pas indisposer Poutine
vous parler du rassemblement national
aussi qui est financé par les Russes
donc est-ce que vous croyez que cette
guerre est éternelle au fond qu'elle ne
se résoudra jamais ou pas à terminer un
brièvement
je pense que ça dépend de nous on peut
faire en sorte que l'Ukraine gagne cette
guerre les Ukrainiens ne nous demande
pas d'envoyer des soldats sur place
c'est la ligne rouge que nous ne
franchirons jamais mais par contre on
doit tout faire pour que l'Ukraine
remporte cette guerre et on doit arrêter
de tergiverser sur les livraisons
d'avions ou sur les livraisons de tank à
chaque fois il faut de aux Ukrainiens
tous les moyens qui sont nécessaires à
leur victoire pourquoi parce que
justement ça nous permettra d'éviter un
conflit éternel parce que aussi ce sera
un message envoyé aux autres poutines de
ce monde
une chose très simple vous ne pourrez
pas avoir raison de nous oui nos
sociétés peuvent être fatiguées oui nos
sociétés peuvent être endormie mais nous
ne céderons pas la lassitude et nous
sommes encore capables de faire preuve
de fermeté et c'est dans ces moments là
qu'il faut savoir faire preuve de
fermeté précisément pour éviter un
conflit éternel et direct très bien gars
merci beaucoup d'avoir partagé
l'esprit dans lequel vous avez écrit cet
essai la grande la grande confrontation
la dernière phrase il est temps de dire
et de montrer ce que nous sommes et ce
que nous voulons être merci beaucoup
Raphaël josman le livre est disponible
ici en librairie à bientôt au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI